a very happy birthday to braxton garrett
this is his 24th birthday his fifth
start of the season 437 era we are at
second and alonso at first and nobody
out and dom gets a breaking ball and
lines it into right field for a base hit
vyard a third he'll be held there
against the arm of de la cruz and that
loads the bases with nobody out
there's a look at the change-up for
garrett he strikes out davis and gets
out number one
and it's javier baez
bases loaded and one out now
sinker gets him back to back strikeouts
and there or two away yeah that's a
fantastic job by alfaro and garrett
three and one
and conforto with a fly ball out to
center field sierra is underneath it
and braxton garrett
just magical loads the bases and works
out of it there's hill making his third
start for the mets
not a very big lead for chisholm
and the curve ball bounce to short they
have to hurry to get two the flip to vr
and on to first just in time to get
alfaro turrie tire the side it's gonna
bring up brian de la cruz
and now this one is smoked out to left
field gonna get down for a base hit
anderson on his way to third here comes
the throw
and it's a two out single for brian de
la cruz
de la cruz is coming to play today with
a pretty good series against the mets
going four for 12 picks on a first pitch
breaking ball and lines it into that
left field corner
curve ball rolled over down to first
alonzo handles it nice job by hill
against the left-hand hitter to get
himself out of the inning two balls in a
strike here on miguel rojas to ground
out his first time up payoff pitch from
rich hill to miguel rojas
[Music]
there's a base hit through the right
side for miggy
a one-out knock
and that one is booted out there in
right-center field rojas is going to
head to second
kids that's why you take an aggressive
turnaround first you come out of the box
roaring
you don't have to be going uh you know
full speed but you're anticipating this
happening and as soon as it does you're
ready to take the extra base
runner goes great jump for rojas
no throw
gets to third with less than two outs
connor in scoring position for jazz
do it again on 3-2 the pitch from hill
this one is lifted out toward left
center field
smith moving back he'll make the catch
and an easy fly ball
just gets the job done a sac fly there
for jazz chisholm junior and the marlins
are on the board one nothing that's here
with the tying run at second the
go-ahead run at first in the fifth
inning
runners go on 3-2 and he swings and
misses alfaro applies the tag and
braxton garrett
has retired maez three times on
strikeouts and a big one to get through
five and the met strand two more that's
eight in five innings
one two coming to jackson
and he golfs one into center field on
comes elmora diving to make the catch
albert almora covering a lot of ground
luis rojas said he was in there because
hill's a fly ball pitcher and elmore is
his best center fielder and elmora makes
that move pay off with a diving grab not
much doubt about almora junior's defense
he was playing over toward right center
had to come over into left center to
haul in that sinking line drive and did
it adeptly like he usually does
so now elmora who came in to this game
with three hits for the season and he's
gone two for two today
he lines one the other way that's a fair
ball going down the line and into the
corner now more going to second dela
cruz picks it up fires to second and
he's safe he got around the tag by rojas
rojas felt as though he got elmora
second base umpire stu surewater called
him safe and we'll see if the marlins
challenge the call
and the marlins are going to challenge
the call de la cruz we mentioned earlier
in the game has shown off a fine arm and
he made another good throw
well he plays it off the carrum there
real well let's see if he got the tag in
nope not from that angle you can't
overturn
does not look as though he got him rojas
felt certain that he had tagged him
but he came up completely empty
and they call him safe so it's a double
for almora here's vr who had an infield
hit in the first since then it's
grounded on fly down
the yard lofts one out to left center
field falling fast base hit around third
out more he'll score the tying run
jonathan villard dumps the basin in
front of brimson on an 0-2 pitch and the
mets tie the game it's 1-1 in the sixth
[Applause]
just stayed compact there fastball had
too much play stayed level on that
fastball up
and here you've got kind of a spacious
ballpark so after two out and nobody on
the double by almora
ruled safe on review
a walk to nemo and vr cashes a run i
said o2 it was a 1-2 pitch
nonetheless vr with his 24th rbi to get
the meds even bring in paul campbell
this will be his sixth game this year
and his first appearance since returning
from a suspension was on the restricted
list tested positive for a banned
substance
into left field brenson is there
and the inning is over the mets have had
roughly a billion base runners there's
joe panic
and that is into center field to base it
through that vacated left side up the
middle and panic is aboard two on nobody
out but he's not bunting and he hits one
on the ground to shore it handled by
baez out at second now they got the
runner hung up between second and third
and baez puts the tag on bias starts and
finishes the double play
[Applause]
i don't know what anderson was thinking
whether he thought that was going to be
a line drive
but the ball hit the ground
and bias starts and finishes the double
play
that just takes them out of the inning
what is yeah what is anderson thinking
he must have thought that javier was
going to catch that on the in the air
but he did not
here's alfaro they're at first and
second with one out here in the inning
and familia brings it home
that's a base hit into right field
maggie's getting the green light here's
the throw from conforto and it is
not in time mega gets around the tag
marlins take the lead
i think holly the throw beat him
like right there beat him but i don't
know if mccann ever
made contact with rojo 2-1 miami they're
on the corners with one out here in the
bottom of the eighth inning
into right and it is down and it will
get all the way to the wall jazz is it
easily here comes
[Music]
[Applause]
alfaro going the other way sweet lou
going the other way
alonso is at third davis is at second
conforto is at first so you're tying
runs
and he reaches for it taps it past the
mound right near the bag grabbed by
chisholm he has no play as a run comes
home
bender delivers
and a ground ball to second
jazz has it on to first
it's a marlins win
they take three out of four from the
first place new york mets walk a
tightrope in the ninth inning
but all of that insurance that they got
in the bottom of the eight they needed
it now six and three against the mets
this year
you